on en vient maintenant je vous le disais
en titre à une célèbre bataille dans la
région dont on fête cette année le 150e
anniversaire
il s'agit de la bataille de châteaudun a
opposé une armée allemande à une armée
française le 18 octobre 1870 la bataille
s'est déroulée après la défaite de
lempire à sedan deux mois plus tôt voilà
pour les faits on en parle tout de suite
avec notre invité le maire de châteaudun
fabien verdier bonsoir monsieur le maire
cent cinquante ans après pourquoi est ce
important en quelques mots de commémorer
cette bataille finalement parce que
c'était une bataille héroïque où les
dunois zélés du noir ont résisté face
aux prussiens le 18 octobre 1870 ce qui
a valu à châteaudun d'être la cinquième
ville de france à avoir la légion
d'honneur une bataille je crois qu'il ya
eu des conséquences au plan national
avec entre autres l'avènement de la
troisième république
oui tout à fait puis elle a une
résonance même internationale à chicago
en irlande en parler de châteaudun de ce
fait historique sur la place du 18
octobre air devant la mairie sur la
place centrale de notre ville de
châteaudun et du noise éliminant ont
vaillamment résisté y en avait 1 pour 10
prussiens y avait des francs-tireurs il
y avait des tirailleurs girondins c'est
un lieu de résistance pendant cette
bataille visant 110 il convient de se
remémorer ceux-là de commémorer cela et
de faire notre devoir de mémoire
malgré le coronavirus ou alors justement
de nombreuses festivités ont lieu
jusqu'à dimanche festivités qui ont
commencé à se dérouler à l'heure où on
se parle comment vous allez gérer sans
cette période où notre pays est à
nouveau et bien placée en état d'urgence
sanitaire
avec toutes les précautions sanitaires
sur le port du masque obligatoire en
tout lieu et en tout temps avec les de
gel à l'entrée avec un protocole
sanitaire affirmé nous avons eu de
nombreuses manifestations cet été comme
le premier festival du loir où dans
notre théâtre municipal cas près 300
places nous avons une exigence sur ce
sujet mais nous devons faire ce devoir
de mémoire avec une vigilance sanitaire
particulièrement renforcés et je crois
pour terminer qui a humilié une légion
d'honneur qui n'est pas passée inaperçue
du côté de châteaudun tout à fait le
patrice de mcmahon qui était président
de la république en 1877 par un décret
le 3 octobre 1817 à conférer à
châteaudun la possibilité d'utiliser la
légion d'honneur la croix de la légion
d'honneur dans ses armoiries de la ville
mais aujourd'hui à l'honneur ceci pour
cet acte de résistance il y aura
stéphane bern demain matin à 11 heures à
châteaudun ya des animations tout au
long de cette soirée et et ce samedi à
des conférences au théâtre cette
exposition il ya des moments de danse
toujours avec le mas toujours avec une
sécurité sanitaire renforcée mais pour
se remémorer ces femmes et ces hommes
font combattu comme laurentine proust en
1870 qui ont apporté leur soutien à la
france pour combattre face aux prussiens
et puis durci l'ambassade d'allemagne
qui sera présente demain matin pour
rappeler aujourd'hui les liens d'amitié
entre la france et l'allemagne est donc
dans une europe qui vit en paix qui a la
chance de vivre en paix depuis plusieurs
décennies
oui c'est important de le rappeler
effectivement merci fabien verdier
d'avoir été notre invité on vous
souhaite bien sûr un bon week-end de
commémorations à châteaudun